um let's start right here from patreon
David Laval sent this in great
conversation with Bill burr and it was
cool to see him giving you some feedback
and advice from a guy who's been on top
of the game for a long time was there
anything in particular he said that
resonated with you or made you think
differently about comedy and your career
thank you David little avail la balle um
you know it was it was it was tough too
it was tough it was tough I was really
really glad that bill came in he and I
had never had a long conversation in
person before ever we had a couple of
conversations on the phone and so I
think it was kind of a new you know I
don't know if we knew each other's vibes
that well I mean Donald the key knew
mine very well and that makes sense you
know I mean I'm an oyster you know I'm a
barnacle and he's a cruise ship you know
and it was tough and it was it was tough
like I couldn't it was just a tough
conversation man it just wasn't I wasn't
bad you know what it was in hindsight it
was exactly what I should have expected
you know he's bill burr he's the reason
there's a reason that that I think he's
the best because he's just you know he
is just he's a train man he's just a
train and he has his thoughts and he has
his his ideas and his and he's poignant
about him and I don't know if I had
expectations in my head that it was
going to be more of like a jovial
chatter or I just think our you know I
just think our ideas of of conversation
or the way we we conversate are just
different a little bit and and he is
exactly what I you know he's really he
was but he was bill burr to a tee he's
brash he's he's he's pulling it he's
exactly he's exact
you know he's he's really he really is
like a like a NASA you know like a
rocket you know and I'm more like
sometimes like feel LARM strong you know
you find me to kind of moseying around
on the moon you know monitoring how I
feel and he's more he's that
master-blaster
he'll shoot right by you and so yeah
there were some things he said that
really did kind of resonate with me I
think when he said that you have to work
well with others you know he kind of
said you got to get over not working
with others um and I think some of that
is true it's like I got a look at myself
and it's like well if I'm gonna be work
in certain circles then I have to be
sure that I'm comfortable with it but I
got a I kind of have to make a decision
so I'm not waffling all the time because
half my choices you could put syrup on
him [ __ ] they waffles you know I'm here
I'm there I got butter I got you know
modren so who knows so that was pretty
good um what else did I take away from
it I definitely I came away feeling like
like it was probably good like if I had
some ego that maybe this was letting
some air out of it you know I fell
sometimes like I couldn't like I didn't
know what to say
and I don't know if that's the best
place to be sometimes you're supposed to
be interviewing somebody or having a
conversation with them but I'm not like
you know I wasn't disappointed in myself
or anything like that I just I think
we're two different types of people you
know when we talked about material and
stuff and I said well I treasure my
material more and for me that's because
I do stories I tell stories you know and
so for me those things are personal and
they're more you know there's more of a
personal value to them in that sense but
I think overall I think no matter what
you know I was great
to be able to have him come in he's you
know he is who we thought he was and we
let him off the hook that's what I feel
like you know he's exactly you know he
was bill bird to a tea to a tea and he
was exactly who the thing that I loved
about him on stage is exactly what I
loved about exactly what he was in
person and so you know I think I think
some of this stuff about Manning up and
sacking up and I think that's right I
think I needed to hear that it doesn't
mean that I can't still be myself for
that but it's nice to sometimes just you
know sometimes you want to hear people
need to hear you sometimes only certain
ways you can hear something
you know sometimes somebody will beat
you with the damn bat but if you don't
care who's beating you you won't you
only pay attention you'll just have bat
marks all over your back and legs inside
and you know an F elsewhere but but
every now and then somebody who you know
who holds some weight in your life will
hit you with that bat with a bat full of
facts brought that fact bat and get you
[ __ ] together
you need a man up so I think it was
sometimes tough to like kind of joke
around or what our what our vibes were I
think we're just kind of off you know
again I'm more like that feel Armstrong
and he's more like a little bit more
like Rocket Man but I'm grateful that
I'm grateful that he came in and uh and
that's really I guess let me think is
there anything else anything
particularly resonated with your main
thing differently about comedy and your
career you know I think it made me think
that if I'm gonna get involved with
Hollywood and that sort of stuff that I
need to kind of come to some peace with
it you know I think somewhere inside of
me sometimes I have a lot of just trust
issues overall in every space of my life
and commitment issues and every in every
aspect you know I don't want to be
exploited I don't want someone to take
advantage of me so it's a lot of fear
[ __ ]
so you know I don't think there are any
any accidents I think everything happens
for a reason and and so yeah it's like
what can I take away from that
experience so I think that's most of my
thoughts on it you know sometimes always
how to kind of spoken up a little bit
more but I think I just didn't really
know kind of what to expect or whatever
and so once things kind of got just
going in this just direction I was like
I felt like I was on a um you ever when
you're learning to ride a bike and you
start the first time it starts going and
you're like you're like I can't get it I
can't get it and then it's going you're
like wow and then you just crash right
into the side of uh Colgate toothpaste
blue Chevelle you know and this [ __ ]
gets down and starts talking [ __ ] doing
it's not even hers she's just sitting in
it smoking so it was kind of like that
you know I just things got going
downhill or going you know down bill and
I couldn't you know I just was on for
the ride at a certain point and um so
yeah I think it was in some ways it was
a learning experience and I don't even
know what I learned from it sometimes
but I'm sure that certain things will
pop up and I was just you know I'm glad
that I got to sit down with somebody
that I really really I mean he's just so
fearless you know he's just so fearless
and I wish I would have asked him more
about like parenting a little bit uh you
know about things you know what things
that he loves about his wife I don't
know I was kind of thinking about stuff
like that I could have asked him you
know you know more about like his
material and what does it mean when he
gives it away and that sort of thing but
we're also at different points in our
career so him you know you know the
world that he's living in is different
than the one that I'm living in but but
yeah you know I think I just take from
it what I can and and I you know and in
the end just be glad that he came and
sat down with me you know I could let it
kind of hurt my ego a little and I don't
think it did that but I think if there
was some
you go in needed to be corrected then
you know humility is always even though
it's painful sometimes it's a it's a
rabbit that I'll let you know run around
in my shirt so I'll get that a little
frickin bunny that'll bust my bust my
ego up and put it in my shirt sometimes
and let that [ __ ] hop around bro and
just show my chest to it you know how
I'm doing it so